welcome back
um we're now going to do the lab for
chapter 11 the survival
analysis chapter
and we have three data sets we're going
to look at and the first one is the
brain cancer data Rob do you want to
tell us a little bit about the brain
cancer data well it's a data set of 88
patients who suffer from brain cancer
I'm looking at their Survival
how long they survived
um
with brain cancer and looking the
survival is a function of sex and most
importantly the diagnosis category of
brain cancer as well as other other
factors okay great so these data on the
ISL and R2
um in the package
and this lab we're going to do a little
differently instead of actually stepping
through the code we're going to take the
output of the markdown which is a nice
HTML file and this looks very similar to
the what you have in the in the chapter
in the book except it's got the output
as well shown the plots and whatever are
shown as well
and it looks really nice so
the brain cancer data is in the package
as we say and we say names and
the other names any particular ones of
Interest Europe uh as I mentioned the
sex looking potential sex differences
and the diagnosis category is yeah
potential interest of importance yeah
and these others are described in the
book I believe this was konovsky index
which is a mouthful we look at the
breakdown of six and roughly balanced
right male and female 45 43
and these are the diagnostic categories
different types of of brain cancer
and Status which is how many died
so those are the the ones are they wrong
that's the ones and the zeros are
censored yeah
so
we do make a point here that
um
you you need to check so status one is
is death year it's very easy to to code
status this is the center in variable
the other way around and you want to
make sure you get it right right so we
know there were 35 deaths in the brain
cancer data and so status one means
death
so the first thing we do is we'll plot a
Kaplan Maya survival curve as shown in
the text and for that we use a serifit
function
and it uses a formula
and a particular
incantation for the response
so there's a function serve which takes
a time and the status the status is is
part of the the response whether it's
centered or not
and in this case we we just model it as
as we model it as one a constant so we
just want a marginal survival curve
for all the data okay and
so that Surfer does that for you
and then you can plot it there's a plot
method and
it by default plots the confidence
interval for the plugs I believe that's
plus or minus two standard errors I
think so yeah yeah
um so that's the defaults and so there
you have the Kaplan my curve
and now you can
you can make instead of putting a turtle
one on the right of the formula you can
put a stratifying variable so here we
put sex which is binary and we do it
again and we can specify colors for the
for the two Sexes and and we can put a
legend in the plot as well and there we
get it and you can see when you stratify
the default is not to put standard
errors because the picture gets a little
cluttered but you can add them if you
want and so you can see if you can
figure out how to do that by looking at
the surfer function and the and the plot
method and one of the questions we're
going to ask pretty soon is are there
are these two different right they look
to be
somewhat different around 40 months for
example but of course there's variation
here and it's a small data set so yeah
we'll have to do a proper test right so
it looks like the men are doing a bit
worse than than woman yeah right so the
first thing we do is perform a log rank
test to compare the survival times of
males to females and that was described
in in the text and
there's a function servedif that does
that for you
and
it's uses the same
response object created by serve and
total sex tells you that you you do the
log rank test to test if the males are
different from females
and then you print out the results
and it seems like it's not significant
the p-value is 0.2 and one thing to
remember with sensor data is oh the
sample size was 88 sounds pretty big
the action model of information is
really more to do with the number of
failures right number of events which
was only about half of that so the real
sample size is a lot less than 88 and
that's why we're getting maybe you know
these although they look pretty the
curves look pretty different the p-value
is not significant right okay it says
here p-value is 0.23 it seems to have
got truncated here
okay so next we're going to fit a Cox
proportional hazards model using the Cox
pH function
we'll start off by fitting using just
sex as the only predictor notice we're
using the same formula in several
incantations here but here we call in
Cox pH
and we fit the model and we do a summary
of the fit
and this gives it a little bit more
detailed summary
and so if you recall this is fitting a
Model A linear model where the the
modification of the Baseline has it is
in this case just a single e to a single
parameter which is
um is the binary indicator of six
and it comes up with a p-value of also
point two
so is that exactly the same as the the
log rank test run yes it is the score
the score test the third of those three
is exactly the equivalent to the log
rank test exactly equivalent
and uh
you can see that here yeah and you can
see that here as well yeah these are
rounded again let's scroll back up to
the survival curves remember the
proportional hazard's assumption assumes
that the relative risk is constant
throughout the whole study right
and it looks like here that you that
might be violated as well right looks
like the relative risk is pretty the
first
five or ten months is pretty equal and
then the females may have an advantage
for
or the middle period right right so of
course it's hard to tell with such a
small data set whether that's that's
causing a problem
and if it was proportional what would
you expect to see we expect to see that
the Gap would be
would start small and would it would
widen as you go along I think I see so
it means the ratio is constant right the
relative yes the ratio of is constant
okay so where were we so we just yeah we
got down here and we saw the log rank
test yeah yeah on the score and the
score test equivalence okay okay
now we're going to add some additional
predictors to the model
and so we add them all in we had sex we
had in diagnosis
and these other three variables
and now we fit the model and you get the
output when we print the output you get
something like a linear model fit
accepted for for the Cox model so
there's a coefficient for each of the
variable
diagnosis is a three category variable
four category variable
and so it uses one of the levels as the
Baseline and that's men in meningiomi is
a Baseline
and and so these are all relative to
that Baseline these these numbers over
here
so in in fact
2.4 this e to the coefficient that's a
relative risk of
HG glioma relative to meningitioma so
remember now so a positive coefficient
is confusing is actually correlates with
a shorter survival right because the
risk is higher
whereas a negative coefficient
correlates with longer survival because
the risk is lower I see that's often
confusing but
so these these guys are these categories
are worse off than than that Baseline
right right in fact all three of them
are yeah so this is the this is the
mildest
um one
and
that one's significant
this is strongly significant there's a
few more this well one more this
konovsky index Ki is also significant
and none of the others are significant
remember all the things we talked about
for linear models and interpreting these
multivered fits still hold here as well
right that these P values talk are
really referring to if we hold all other
variables fixed what's the the predicted
effect of changing that variable I see
right
right so yeah right so if some of these
other variables are for example
correlated right
um
they could be showing no
non-significance because the other one's
standing in for it right so these P
values are all what happens if you drop
that variable out the model but leave
all the others in exactly yeah
finally we plot the survival curves for
each diagnosis category adjusting for
the other predictors
so that the diagnostic category seems to
be important at least one of them is
important
so we want to leave all the other
predictors in the model
and when you plot the survival curves
you need to the the output of a Cox pH
model is for each subject when you make
a prediction you get a whole survival
curve
okay so we need to specify what the
other values of the predictors are
so when we want to focus on on the
diagnosis category what we do is we set
some typical values for the other
parameters and if they quantitative
we'll just set the mean value and if
they categorical we'll set the modal
value because we need to put some value
in for all the predictors
and one of the reasons we have to do
that here right is this model is really
is different than a linear model we
effective one variable does not depend
on the levels of the others right but
this model is
in a certain way it's sort of non-linear
right so the effect of each variable
actually depends on the levels of the
other that's it yeah we saw the same
thing in in in the logistic model where
we think we saw that or it's true in the
logistic model that when you look at
probabilities and the effect of a
variable on the probabilities of
response it depends on the levels of the
other variables right right and that's
the same here now so not only will these
survival curves shift up and down
depending on the levels of the other
variable to the values of the other
variables but the shape will change as
well because it's it's not just a shift
it's a the proportional Hazard thing
again it's a
the slope also changes
okay so here we have it and
sure enough meningioma has the best
survival history the HG glioma is the
worst and that remember that had the
highest relative risk
and then it looks like LG glioma and the
Alva are very similar to each other
they're almost completely on top of each
other
right
so
that's a result and this plot nicely
separates it and illustrates it